I was introduced to ashraf
for kerala mac
with ashraf in an organization of
survivors of terrorist attacks the
global survivors network and she had a
number of people who had survived the
who had who were victims of her hood
survived terrorist attacks and what
struck me about ostrov was partly what
you had said which is that he is
motivated out of not out of anger or
revenge but really out of hope and he's
taken this tremendous tremendously
horrible experience and turned it into
something really incredible and it's
taking a message of non-violence around
the world and taking it to some really
really difficult audiences and now to me
was his his spirit and his his
forward-looking and his the absence of
recrimination that he had was really
inspiring to me so I wanted to follow
his story well I started filming
veterans about a year and a half before
I met Robin and they were involved in
something called the combat paper
project and similar to rough and turn
taking something negative and turning it
to something positive they were taking
their uniforms they war in Iraq and
cutting them up and beating them to a
pulp and making our paper and art out of
them and so I initially got involved in
this project but I felt like I needed
something more and so when I met Robin I
she was going about to embark in a whole
VA process which is a very long grueling
process and it can it just it's very
they treat you like you're just a number
and so I really wanted to show this
aspect of what it's like to be a veteran
to go through the VA and so I feel her
for about a year and her story just took
on this other life and I didn't know how
to fit her story into my other film that
I was working on the verte footage was
so extraordinary that I felt that once
there was a string out it was clear that
without Sarah shooting another foot of
film there would be a spectacular
because we rarely get that close to
someone at so many points in their life
and the arc of her story has a happy
ending there have been a number of
screenings all over Israel several at
the Tel Aviv cinematheque I'm one
entirely for the population of the
school and interestingly enough in this
conflict-ridden region the irony of this
film has brought a lot of attention to
the school we've gotten numerous emails
and for people wanting to contribute
money to the school and film festivals
all over all over the world particularly
in the Middle East don't underestimate
the number of jewish film festivals in
the world in in 2008 i came across a
humanitarian alert about the Carteret
islands there being because of global
warming and rising seas they're being
forced to go out and look for a new
homeland the saltwater inundates they're
freshwater sources and their gardening
land and so when we went there the clan
chiefs from the island had selected a
group of their strongest young leaders
to go out and essentially start paving
the way for the relocation to this much
larger mountainous island 50 miles
across the open ocean a few of the
Islanders Nick and Kathleen who are our
main characters and stand out in this
clip that you saw did speak a little bit
of English and they also spoke pigeon
which is of all of the foreign languages
that that's about the easiest to learn
so we picked up enough to understand a
little bit in a few weeks one of our
supporter visited that area in 2007 the
spring of 2007 she said that they're
interesting NGO working in that area and
she said why don't you go take a look at
that region and at that time we finish
two films and
I would like to work on a environmental
film at that time so she was very
instrumental telling us about the story
but it was the film was shown at with
environmental groups selected groups and
they very excited about the film ok I
just say one other quick thing which is
to look at those five excerpts is to
really be blown away by the reach of
American documentary film right now I
mean it's just it's in it from a point
of view of competition it's totally
intimidating but but from the point of
view of looking at the whole field it's
really exhilarating i was really knocked
out
you